hello everybody my name is boy what the
[ __ ] was that don't do that that is a
really douchey thing to do why did it
just jolt me back okay so I can't go
down there anymore
hi almost overlooked this hey cool what
do we got
classified notes oh there's me
okay location 1880 Washburn Hill that
was the location that the little girl is
told to remember with the gun all right
subject has been patterned to execute a
covert mission to neutralize Blair a
federal prosecutor believed to possess
classified Blair documents done in doses
reward suggests asset documents are in
his personal firearm located as often
room for survives having at eleven
eighty watt Ranil neutralized Blair
destroyed Blair documents subject notes
subject has been overall reacting very
well to the treatment some signs of
resistance were spotted early on a short
room therapy was applied for a period of
three months to positive efforts
subject has displayed an infection tie
to a partner on the assignment subject
ninety seven but we do not see any
performance issues of the results of
this we will monitor their interactions
closely leading up to the deployment
both subjects entered the hello Hector
program around the same time and were
admitted due to arson related
infractions however was black I was
never on not a little Korean village
they were understandably doubts about
pairing ninety eight with him due to the
severity of his infractions because of
the sensitive nature of the assignment
some redundancies were added to ensure
its success while completing I think I
am the other subject
that's probably Who I am and it's
probably the reason why I'm hearing that
little herb the girl's voice in my head
oh hey you're back hi just stay away
from me but in you nothin
Oh Sydney oh you barely grazed my nose
god damn that hurt real bad
ow ow my pride is hurt worth him I know
though cuz it didn't actually hurt you
didn't actually hit me okay
that's no hello Oh a choice you said
hello Oh another choice how delightful
Oh an odd choice great I'll go right
thanks eyeless dude thanks i list dude
number two thanks eyeless dude number
three and four you don't get your full
name red I don't like you show me you
always show me your gun Fuu oh this room
looks great
oh hey am I gonna start the fire
am I in 1180 I'm in 1180 Arnot oh I see
okay so I need to go back to the other
avenue and then go the other direction I
am an arsonist that's why I'm hearing
stop the water start the fire stop the
water start the fire oh four five seven
that's the that's the room I'm supposed
to enter it eleven eighty because this
whole thing was just brainwashing me
submit Mars or murder someone what is
dark here
well that was effective
oh he's vanished into blood okay then
already that so I'm imagining the other
girl that I've been seeing
hallucinations of was my partner in
crime it got dark is that the sound of
blood my blood cool all right great
hey I started the fire good for Mama
leather go I better get that guy's dead
we did good we did her job
hello stop the water start the fires
down the water start the fire south
order we stop the water I stop the
sprinklers Oh
oh hey look at window hey lady to the
window to the wall over there it's
getting hot near sweat dropping down
anything you know so they want to get in
we obviously done bad we're gonna burn
we're gonna burn oh no no I'll just wing
it it ends oh no oh no oh is that a
collectible yeah I got a collectible
everything's gonna be okay lady I don't
even know your name
well alright
well okay good well I'm right on top of
her sitting on her own great grace great
hug now
okay yeah I died
how's that Oh God
what a way to end it like I knew
something was going on the whole thing
was just a test to get my brain
programmed to do something but it was
actually kind of cool because like it
with the representative the levels in
this game we're actually really
intriguing to the story because it was
the same place that was the very theme
at achill II thing that you needed to
know it was the same place repeated a
million times because you didn't know
where you were gonna go it was a really
good game like that was really cool
no a problem was like why was the
monster there I think the monster was
just a device to create a little more
scare and risk into the game and what I
didn't need to be there but it did add a
little element of panic and chase but
still like this is a good game for the
technology that it had it wasn't very
well polished or anything it wasn't like
triple-a quality it was still very good
for an indie company I would actually
say that this is not bad at all like I
had a lot of fun playing this idol I had
a great time figuring out the story
because story was told very piecemeal
now another problem I had is in the last
segment of it where I was trying to find
the chess pieces where I found page
after page after page after page of
notes notes notes notes notes notes and
going from the situation where I was
completely lost suddenly I'm finding all
these pieces of the story
it kind of was fee matically different
but not entirely unrelated to everything
else it still helped piece it together
quickly but I imagine that the game had
to be wrapped up pretty soon as many of
these indie development games do but it
was still very good for what it was I
think the team is only five people large
not a bad game at all I really enjoyed
it I hope you did too
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you thought of this
game in the description below that's
great it's totally pitch black great
everything's dead I'm dead we're all
dead not you guys you're not dead you're
alive in my heart but my heart that's
probably burned up too so thank you
everybody so much
check out the other scary and cool games
that I played in the annotations over
there or in the description below I
played a lot of them check him out check
out some amnesia custom stories because
a lot of us kind of remind me of Andy a
lot of it kind of reminded me of a
number
which was very interesting but I got a
lot of inspiration for various game
vanish penumbra that other game that I
mentioned a few episodes back they're
all really cool so check it out thank
you again everybody and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye just
like this horror story I don't know what
specific